now to the latest battleground in the
fight over abortion rights this was the
scene in indiana state houses lawmakers
there considered a near total ban
cbs evening news anchor and managing
editor norah o'donnell sat down with
someone who's become a symbol of this
debate that's dr caitlin bernard who's
an ob gyn in indiana who according to
state records obtained by cbs news
provided a medication abortion to a
ten-year-old rape victim from
neighboring ohio that state already bans
most abortions after six weeks because
of privacy laws dr bernard can't confirm
this was her patient but in her first tv
interview she spoke about what the end
of roe v wade means for doctors
i think we're at a time in our country
where people are starting to realize the
impact of these anti-abortion laws and
now when it's finally become impossible
for some people i think people realize
that that is actually not what they
intended that is not what they want for
children for women to be put in these
situations of life-threatening
conditions of traumatic pregnancies when
your name was publicly attached to this
case the attorney general of indiana
said he would investigate you what was
your reaction
it's been really difficult indiana's
attorney general todd rokita described
you as an abortion
activist acting as a doctor
how do you respond to that
i'm a physician i've spent my entire
life working to have this position to be
able to take care of patients every
single day did you at any point violate
privacy laws
no and have you failed to report any
recent abortions no how would you
describe how things have changed since
the supreme court overturned roe versus
wade we're hearing stories all across
the country of people who are in dire
circumstances complications of their
pregnancies or traumatic situations and
are needing abortion care and not able
to get it is it worse than you imagined
it's worse faster you've spent your life
your career taking care of and providing
care for women and babies
what has this supreme court decision
done you know this will affect our
ability to take care of miscarriages
this will affect our ability to
take care of complications in early
pregnancy that could kill someone this
will affect our ability to provide
infertility treatment
contraception the list goes on how would
you address concerns by conservatives or
those with deeply held religious beliefs
that abortion is immoral and wrong what
i would say is if you don't believe that
you would have an abortion then don't
have one
you cannot stop other people from
accessing medical care that they need
based on your personal religious beliefs
you would never want somebody to do that
to you
dr bernard told us the indiana attorney
general has only just reached out to her
and her lawyer for the first time nearly
two weeks after saying he would
investigate her dr bernard is also
pursuing a defamation case against him i
think the point that she makes at the
end it's very powerful yeah it's
critical yeah because you believe it's
wrong and it's against what you believe
then don't have one don't have one the
simplicity in which she said it makes
you go oh okay right puts it in
perspective i thought so yeah i agree